with over 300 sessions at next 2023 it's
understandable that you couldn't get to
them all so if you didn't see optimize
your Google Cloud costs with proven
datadriven approaches then stay tuned
because here's the
[Music]
rewind want to do more with less
managing ongoing economic headwinds and
financial
uncertainty while innovating for
business value
all on a tight budget and keeping your
team motivated can be huge tasks and on
recent surveys cost optimization has
been top of mind for the seventh year in
a row with roughly 62% of companies
focused on optimizing their existing use
of cloud but identifying The Sweet Spot
of low effort high value actions can be
tough without alignment from your team
on a clear
Plan cost optimization goes beyond
pricing and extends into knowing where
to invest and maximize
value involving tools and accelerators
accountability and enablement
measurement and
realization cost optimization and
planning and forecasting and beyond that
basic framework there are three key
areas for cost optimization on cloud the
first is resource optimization which can
be accomplished by evaluating where you
might be spending when you don't have to
actions like identifying idle VMS and
databases rightsizing over-provisioned
resources and using autoscaling wherever
possible can be powerful steps towards
reducing your Cloud spend and these
actions can be a joint effort between
product and Engineering teams so
everyone is able to do their job as
effectively as possible the next area
for cost and value optimization is
optimizing your rates could you
potentially be paying different rates
for the same resources you're using for
example with committed use discounts for
your predictable workloads you could
realize a significant savings the same
goes for big query reservations where
you can consolidate the analytics needs
for your organization and centrally make
decisions based on the data the third is
optimizing your architecture much like
the first two areas for cost and value
optimization the third also involves a
cross team effort to align on what
resources are needed and how to best set
them up to increase or maintain value
without necessarily increasing spend by
virtue of moving to the cloud you can
see a reduction in total cost of
ownership because you're no longer
managing data storage on site and by
embracing further managed services and
serverless Technologies you can compound
those savings and free up some of your
team's time enabling you to focus more
on innovating as you can see there are
many players that need to be involved
from cross functional teams in getting
an accurate picture of your usage and
determining what discounting or
automation can be used to optimize
performance and costs it takes
consistent collaborative effort to have
a successful Cloud finops team who can
work iteratively on three phases inform
optimize and operate as quoted by finops
Foundation keeping fops collaborative is
a critical way to accomplish these goals
and using the right tools and processes
to empower your teams can be a great
place to start to allow for this level
of collaboration to make datadriven
decisions it takes cultural adjustments
too aligning on labeling strategies and
performance expectations are some ways
to be more proactive in your approach
and enable near realtime
reporting our panelists spoke to lunch
and learns workshops incentivized
hackathons and even regular meetings as
powerful ways to support a culture of
empowered collaboration and aligned
efforts in finops and better yet if
you're just getting started you can
design your finop strategy to be
efficient and collaborative as you start
your transformative Journey with us on
the cloud to make sure your finop
strategy is aligned with your cost and
value goals remember to evaluate your
Cloud strategy with the three finops
pillars optimize your resources optimize
your rates and optimize your
architecture and don't forget to account
for cultural adjustments that might be
needed to create an aligned environment
for your teams to collaborate
effectively and succeed then you can
take action on the various areas for
improvement or design a strategy that
works best for you if you'd like to see
the full talk check out the link in the
description and don't forget to
subscribe to our YouTube channel for
more great next rewind content thanks
for
watching